uh well let's discuss all of that uh
with the labour mp john mann uh chair of
the all party parliamentary group and on
anti-semitism mr man thanks very much
for being with us
just that line from joan ryan's letter i
cannot remain a member of the labour
party while this requires me to suggest
that i believe jeremy corbyn a man who's
presided over the culture of anti-jewish
racism and hatred of israel which now
afflicts my former party
is fit to be prime minister does she
have a point well she certainly has a
point because
there are more important people than mps
resigning from the labour party
young activists resigning and
they're resigning because they think the
labour party is
not prepared to stand up for them young
jewish people
or others who look into what's happening
to their jewish friends and you know if
this if this kind of thing the thing
that happened to luciana berger
if that would have happened under tony
blair tony blair would have acted
that had been said diane abbott who'd
have been picked on and someone tried to
get rid of because she was a lefty
in the blair era tony blair would have
intervened neal kenneth did intervene
um he intervened in tottenham um when
there's very controversial
uh d selections going on um and in
in in that case intervene not for
someone who was of his political
persuasion at all blair would have
intervened
for someone who was uh adamantly opposed
to many of things that he believed in
jeremy corbyn didn't intervene with
luciano burger that was a
terrible error a terrible mistake what
he should have done
that would have with anti-semitism have
created
quite an opportunity to move forward now
it's running backwards all the time
that's the danger that's a problem well
it almost seems like you you're past the
point of no return now so if you're
if you agree with joan ryan will you be
following her then
this is this let us be clear this new
party this new party is a
a remain party it's people who fought
on a manifesto that said uh that we
abide by the
decision the british people took in the
referendum and this new party
will have no credence no credibility in
the midlands the north
precisely because of that that's its
fundamental flaw and that's why
and i call it chucker's group it's
slightly bigger now
um there may be others from across the
chamber following them later on
but well some of those stories um people
such as anna subray justin greening
have been in discussions and negotiation
with chuck and his small group
for the last year so this has been
pre-planned they want to scupper
the referendum they're quite open about
that it's not a secret
but that is not the manifesto labour mp
stood on
what i would do though if i was jeremy
corbyn and i've advised him of this
very recently is when it comes to the
vote on brexit
i would have a free vote of labour mps
because the labour party
is split on the issue of brexit as is
the tory party
that would assist a lot in labour moving
forward
indeed but it strikes me that you know
the comments that jordan ryan has made
in her letter the comments you've made
about jeremy corbyn in the way in which
he's dealt with anti-semitism you know
people within the parliamentary labour
party have been making those
not just for weeks but months years now
about the way in which jeremy corbyn
operates
at least joan at least john ryan has
done something about it
working within the plp you haven't
managed to change anything well i've
been on your program
for the last 16 years you may not have
seen all the clips though i'm sure
actually now you recall them
for the last 16 years calling out
anti-semitism
on the left on the right and saying all
the way through
that one will clean up one's own
backyard first one zone party
i first said that to sky television
about 15 years ago
and i've consistently said it so many of
us have been challenging anti-semitism
well before jeremy corbyn emerged as a
national figure
a known figure well before and i have no
intention of stopping doing so
and neither have any intention but
handing over my party
to the this group of anti-semites who've
infiltrated in
who haven't been thrown out i shall
continue
to campaign and demand if i'm the last
man standing
demanding these anti-semites are removed
from i understand
but at what point does it become
intolerable because it clearly became
for luciano
it's it's intolerable now what's
happened to luciana berger
the anti-semitism's intolerable but some
of us are going to stand and fight
and we will fight to the last and we
will not budge from that
and frankly i don't give a damn what
people
elsewhere in the labour party think
about our stance on fighting
anti-semitism
we will not budge many of us on that we
will carry on fighting
we will cleanse this party whether that
can be done quickly we'll see
whether we have a cataclysmic election
defeat because we're not prepared to act
we will see but we will do so and my
demands on jeremy corbyn
remain the same as they were a week ago
a month ago a year ago
three years ago sought this problem out
why should the constituents of people
like joan ryan luciano barger
and the others why they should they have
to wait years
to get to vote again and who represents
them given that they stood
in 2017 full square behind the manifesto
put forward by a party well if i
if i was to resign and say that i
disagreed with the manifesto that i
stood on i'd stand right immediately
i would struggle to find a policy in the
2017 manifesto that he couldn't that he
did disagree
well i i would stand and fight a
by-election if it was me
i'd put myself to the people i'm not
resigning but if i resigned
i'd put myself to the people and i'd put
it to the test
and i think that some of them should do
that i think
i i think if you're saying that you
speak for the people
then put that to the test but that's
decisions that they will make
uh i suspect they're not going to do
that i suspect there'll be some tory
defections
a small number of of tories people such
as anna subray justin greening
who will leave the tory party as well i
suspect they won't fight by elections
um but you've got to be bold in politics
i'm not resigning i know of others who
are not resigning
who share the same view as me um but but
those who do fight a ballot and let's
have some balancings on it
i mean those who are those who are
returning to the party at the moment
derrick hatton
we learned over the past few days bit of
doubt as to when he actually got back
into the party but well
well there's a red tory derry carton he
supports a 10
he's like john redwood he's like jacob
rees-mogg no inheritance tax
10 income tax wants everyone to be
driving around
in big cars and pay no taxes well who
pays for the national health service
you know these kind of uh uh
working-class tourists like derry catton
he's no different in his policies george
galloway he's also applying to get back
in i think would be it would be a bit of
a push to describe as a as a working
class
there's a man there's a man who did
stand as an independent as a traitor to
the labour party
uh one's a traitor always a traitor so
galloway should not be allowed back in
so that kind of language traitor cowards
is wrong when it's directed
and but it's right when it's directed
galloway was a traitor
as an independent um so it's a bit room
of him to be calling other people
traitors now
um and hatson manhattan was an extremist
marxist militant tendency
you know brought the labour party in
liverpool to its knees led to
the liberals running liverpool for a
huge period of time
attacked the unions sent redundancy
letters to working-class people
i mean that's got nothing to do with
socialism it's going to do with the
labour party
that kind of extremism no surprise
that he's a man who supports the
economics of john redwood and jacob
dries morg
of having the lowest possible taxes in
the world he'd be better off john donald
trump to be honest
you say that they don't represent the
party but you look at the way with which
the
the the glee with which these names are
being discussed and and welcome back
into the
into the full by people who are who are
members of the party is it not possible
that
you say that this is not this is not the
labor party the definition of what the
labour party actually is right now
has changed substantially this is a
battle for the soul of the labour party
well somebody once said he's winning at
the moment and well
there are people refusing to act to
people failing to act there's a chronic
lack of leadership and the kind of thing
that happened to luciana berger
for that to happen in the labour party
is so abhorrent to everything the labour
party has ever stood for
and i'm calling it's about time that the
unions stood up and be counted in
actually getting this sorted out
because the labour party is becoming
unelectable and uh
and frankly jeremy corbyn needs to start
acting as a leader
he's failed to do so when it came to
issues such as luciano berger
and a great opportunity and obvious
opportunity to do so
i hope he's going to do so in the near
future okay so what what can
jeremy corbyn do first of all first and
foremost to to regain your trust
but to put the party back to where it
needs to be to to to win an election and
you know there are already people
talking right now
about the prospect of an election in the
not too distant future well i'm not sure
there will be an election but the first
thing
and not least because the one thing
these defections do
is it ensures that no confidence vote
even with the dup vote if it's not going
to get through parliament
people who've just resigned and haven't
yet formed a party are not going to be
no confidence in the government and
force themselves into an election
so actually one thing this does do
teresa may is probably quite happy today
it gives treason a lot of comfort in
terms of not losing a no-confidence vote
in the next
12 months even if a handful of tories
defect
so there will be no election as a
consequence of this
i think but what what jeremy corbyn
ought to do in the short term the
immediate term
is hold the parliamentary labor party
and the labour party in the country
together
with a free vote on the brexit vote
there is a huge divide in the country
52-48 there's a huge divide in all the
political parties
that would be coherent it would be good
leadership what he then needs to do
is he needs to get on top of this issue
of anti-semitism and he hasn't done so
and he hasn't bothered speaking i mean
you know i'm only one person who don't
need to speak to me go speak to other
people he hasn't spoken to me
he hasn't spoken to others about it most
crucially
he has not been speaking to the jewish
labour mps about it as luciano berger so
eloquently
pointed out he needs to start acting
as a leader in that and thirdly he needs
to think through what is the labour
party about
because you know you've got these
extremists trying to now get rid of it
what they've been trying for the last
year trying to get rid of people like me
and
graham stringer the brexit support and
labour mps
trying to d they're not for this they're
failing miserably in it
but the fact that there's people near to
corbin trying to do it
if the labour party is not a broad
church the labour party doesn't win
power
therefore corbyn is never prime minister
that is a reality
joint man many thanks for being with us